[Music]
ariana grande made sure gwen stefani had
a star-studded send-off in sin city we
are just having the time of our lives on
saturday the sweet escape singer said
goodbye to her las vegas residency show
called gwen stefani just a girl but it
wasn't your average farewell show
[Music]
not only did gwen's hubby blake shelton
join her on stage for a duet ariana was
also there cheering her on throughout
the night but gwen had no idea the thank
you next singer shared snaps from the
concert on her instagram story
[Music]
and ari didn't hold back praising the
hollow back girl singer writing
brilliant gwen stefani congratulations
on completing this incredible run love
you so much
[Music]
for gwen and blake's duet ari had to get
in a crack about her fellow voice coach
writing that's my grandpa blake shelton
i'm so
proud i love this song and you both
that's fun i love a challenge once the
show was over and gwen caught up on her
social media she was stunned by ariana's
show of support i thought i was going to
die the no doubt front woman reposted
ari's videos and asked um ariana grande
you came to my show yay love you thank
you
meanwhile gwen's send-off was also a
date night for blake and ahri's fellow
voice coach john legend and his wife
chrissy teigen the cookbook author wrote
on instagram what a beautiful show gwen
congrats on an incredible run but let's
not forget that before saturday night
ariana was already a huge hashtag
chiffony fan what are your fan club
which was revealed in this hilarious
outtakes from the voice what's you in
gwen's
shafani chicago yeah i didn't hear that
oh i love that one
i stand shafani's
dance stan's them yes yep the love is
real even if we've seen some friendly
antics between the pop star and country
crooner this season
leading up to the season 21 premiere
blake john and kelly all admitted to e.t
that ari was proving to be a fierce
competitor
of course she's a threat she is hugely
talented hugely successful and has a
legion legions and legions of fans
that
that know how to use the internet and
vote
everything he just said
so we all knew it
[Music]
you